how are you Chris hello Richard funny it
was funny once you left
you didn't put me on the record button
yeah what's funny well goodell what 90%
now you you're the NFL guru 90%
performance enhance but I'm assuming
those little performance things reseted
easy to attain yes yeah it's like
rubbing the clear on you know right he's
gonna make did he get the plane I
haven't seen the fine print Chris you
know I'm not on the competition
committee are they the compensation I'm
not any committee I'm just sitting out
here doing my show every day
how you doing you good not bad how you
doing all right I'm trying to figure out
about Aaron Boone what what are you
making us hire I'm surprised they got
rid of Girardi let's start with dad you
know I don't know if who's as much did I
know the Yankees want to make you think
it was a disconnect with the players and
the front office but geez he had a heck
of a season I mean I got to Game seven
against Houston a fly ball by Todd
Frazier if it leaves the ballpark they
get to the World Series so III think
maybe money had a little something to do
with it she already was going to get
paid five million dollars a year or this
next contract boon making four million
for three so you do the math but I think
based on what I've read here and I
didn't see the press conference
yesterday but based on what I read heard
and I you know everybody knows boonie
ESPN everybody seems to think he hit a
home run yesterday 44 years of age hey
you know he knows how to handle the New
York media I think he's willing to do
anything Cashman wants him to do the
Yankee general manager young enough as a
as a former player that may be able to
relate to the players and his team right
now how like some so I think he hit a
home run and obviously we know we hit
the big home owner no three but I think
he had all run in the introductory press
conference but you know the Yankees are
about winning 11 games in October how he
handles those moves would be interesting
yeah I know he takes over I mean a
machine it's it seems it's set up right
why would you listen I mean I think
that's the one-
i mean is the idea although the fans
don't love Girardi they did appreciate
his work ethic and the success they had
last year and the Yankees won
one games they played very well all year
long the right fielders second MVP to
catch hit 34 home runs the shortstop
came into his own Severino was third in
the American League side young Aaron
Hicks played great I mean so nobody can
sit there if they think there was a
disconnect with the players there's no
evidence with Jordy there's no evidence
to support that and then they beat
Cleveland down to oh they didn't give up
on Jordy then and they actually had the
[ __ ] rattled in the ALCS so that's a
tall order for Boone because he goes 85
and 77 it's gonna be a failure if they
win 87 games and lose a wild-card game
that's going to be a failure too but
that's the situation Yankees have put
themselves in by firing Girardi
Christopher mad dog rusev mad dog Sports
Radio from Sirius XM here on the Rich
Eisen show okay I give you the floor on
the McAdoo firing what you think of that
well listen uh the bottom line about the
whole scenario with the Giants is they
hate the fan the fan base hated McAdoo
they not in love with Reese whose aloof
and the giant fan likes to consider
himself above the jet fan Connecticut
Westchester's leafy had season tickets
district high that jet fan is corona
blue-collar and so they think they're
above the jet fan but by golly we're
gonna bench our starting quarterback for
Geno Smith so I think all those things
played into the outrage I think if the
Giants had benched Manning for Davis
Webb I don't think he'd have nearly as
much of an outcry and of Manning and if
Mara had done it and he had the press
conference last week and he wasn't there
originally because he was on line
compensation compensation committee
meetings but if Mara had done it and not
McAdoo I think the giant Fayette fan
base could have handled it a little
better too so you put all the
ingredients in the mix two-time Super
Bowl winner beloved giant quarterback
hey Gino Smith McAdoo 2 & 9 I can't
stand him and Jerry Reese has been here
long enough tell him they hit the
highway - you put all that into the mix
and that is why you had that outcry now
listen the Giants are playing Eli this
week and Beyond Giants got three home
games left there
games are against the Cowboys the Eagles
and the Redskins the Cowboys and Eagles
who travel those fans this both in a
race still those fans are going to show
but the medal at MetLife Mara spagnolo
and everybody else they don't want to
play web or you know a guy like Geno
Smith in that environment
get killed and have the whole place
being run over by cowboy and Eagle fans
play Manning get a little juice with the
fan base everybody gives them a standing
ovation we see what happens on Sunday in
essence is it good for the franchise
they're 2 and 10 they're awful I got the
worst offense in a world why not play
Webb but I don't think Jarrett's gonna
do it they're rich I think you're gonna
play Manning the rest of the year
spot on I mean you could not have hit
every note more perfectly on that Chris
the jet aspect of it is absolutely the
main problem what set people off that it
was Geno Smith that you're gonna bench
Eli you're not gonna give him start
number 2 11 in a row for a guy that we
have had a front row seat seeing go
through everything from flopping to
saving Rex Ryan's job which we all saw
broken by teammates we got ready for a
training camp let's not throw that ad
very on quarterback like if you know
what I mean and very unscientific
it came up just absolutely tone-deaf on
every on every way poorly
McAdoo I think he had the right idea
with Eli I think he wanted to respect
them and McAdoo doesn't communicate
right the media can't stand him he's you
know obviously he thinks he's above it
all you know one thing about that one
thing about New York if you're gonna be
a heart of the media and be a little
arrogant be Belichick be Parcells win
Super Bowls that's right when you go to
a nine you can't do that in New York
City because there's too many fans and
there's too many media guys who are
going to go crazy and you become a
distraction and that's kind of what
happened with Maxwell Kurt Warner said
why did you have to say anything
why did the Giants have to say anything
just keep Eli's starting game gets out
of hand they say we're gonna go to the
kid Davis what the problem is he's not
even ready which is kind of another
indictment I have no question about
added Giants
who had a terrible season right from the
get-go were on five they got a 37 year
old Eli in January he's not gonna be
here forever they knew that a lot of
quarterbacks in his draft the Giants
should have made sure after the bye week
when Eli you know the season was over
when they were going to replace he like
if they had web-ready
working out practice wise taking the
second team snaps the giant fan wouldn't
have liked it but they could have
understood it but the Giants like idiots
didn't have web-ready and Geno Smith as
you said rich nobody wants to see Geno
Smith play a couple more minutes left
with Chris Russo here on the Rich Eisen
show one quarter of the season to go who
do you think makes the Super Bowl wins
it Christopher I think the Patriots are
much better than Pittsburgh I think they
will get out of the ID the Chargers are
dangerous Jacksonville's defense but I
think New England what else is new we'll
get out of the AFC I'm going to say the
Eagles because I think Case Keenum will
put himself on a head do something I
know I know when I'm not Kingdom he's
been great but I can't completely trust
them I think the Rams might be a year
away and I you know the Saints are not
gonna have home-field
I'll give the Eagles a mulligan off the
the Seattle game the Eagles are gonna
win their last together their last three
games
Giants Raiders and I got a game at home
Cowboys Cowboys last game of the year
they're gonna win those three so they're
going to go minimum 13 and 3 and they
might go fourteen and two Saints won't
do that they'll lose a game to Atlanta
or somebody Minnesota could lose the
Rodgers at Green Bay could lose this
week so I'll say Eagles and or chalk
I'll go Eagles patch in a Super Bowl
okay and I probably won't speak to you
before next week when Mike Francesa
signs off what what type of are you a
part of the final did you know they did
a tribute for Mike at the at CW Post on
November 15 right about 4,000 people
that I was about 3,000 I went to that
and I was I was on with him for about 40
minutes I did that he's got a show at
the
any senator of New York next Thursday no
I'm gonna be at the Winter Meetings in
baseball so I don't know what I'm gonna
do with that yet and then a Friday is
his last show so I mean I'm gonna have
to like if they want me I will I got to
make sure I say goodbye to them properly
but it would be sometime late next week
I think Mike will take next two or three
months off I don't think you're gonna
hear from Mike into at the very minimum
the spring okay what do you think it's
gonna do what do you think he's gonna
die I definitely think he be somewhere
next fall with the football I think he's
gonna put want to do a Sunday show he'll
want to do something Fridays and Mondays
you know he loves his summer you know I
you know I don't know where he'd be in
his spring doesn't have to work it's not
like he's gonna be dying to go back on
but I do think you're hear from him
again you would know the podcast world
better than I do but I so who knows
there but I do think you hear from him
again
Christmas I wouldn't rule that out okay
Christopher you the man thanks for
calling right back at you that's
Christopher Mad Dog Russo you're on the
Rich Eisen the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience